How many gods do you have?
Just. Just one.
Just one. Oh,
you're right.
We should only worship god.
You're right.
That's okay.
That's not. I don't break that.
We worship only god. Okay, then.
So who's Jesus?
Jesus is the revelation of the invisible god.
So is Jesus a man?
Absolutely. So he's not god.
He's the Rev.
Like I just said,
he's the revelation or image of the invisible god.
But he's not god. Correct.
He's the one who revealed god to us.
He's not god the father.
We don't believe that he's god the father.
We believe that he is a man.
Call the Messiah,
call the son of god.
That reveals the invisible god.
And because he perfectly reveals the invisible god,
he is god with us.
Is he god or is he not god?
He's the word of god who reveals god. So.
Right. Can I.
Can I ask you something?
Can I wait. Why are you running away?
You. You said you would run away.
I didn't run away from you.
So why are you running away from me?
Why do white people run away from the truth?
They don't wanna hear the fullness of truth.
Can I ask you a question?
I just took a picture of me. Is that me?
That's a picture of you.
Good. So. So Jesus is a picture of god?
Yes, he's a picture. And?
And it's distinct. From god.
It's not god.
But yet he's revealing god.
This reveals me.
But this is not me.